You know,
Scotland's a weird place.
Like you have to dress a certain way when you hunt there,
or at least they have a certain way.
They dress like a traditional way,
but it's not like they don't wear Cammo.
It's like an outfit.
Yeah.
Like what do they wear?
The wear like clothes,
like a weird old timey clothes.
I like that.
I like tradition.
Um,
yeah,
I know you did.
That's why I brought it up.
Bordain went um,
hunting in Scotland because television show,
right?
You had to wear some crazy ass outfit.
You get suited for this outfit,
this traditional hunting outfit and it's pretty cool.
Yeah.
A lot of those that's,
that's traditional places like Scotland too.
If I'm in,
I think most of it was like private land.
Right.
I think back in the day,
like that was what Robin Hood was all about.
Right.
Robin Hood was originally supposed to be about someone who was poaching and
hunting on the king's land because they were hungry.
So they were stealing from the rich to feed the poor gentlemanly pursuit,
hunting and shooting attire.
Wow.
Dress.
Does that help you?
Helps me be a good hunter because aren't you have to goof on them or does it
like does that help?
Does that get in the way of hunting or is that help hunting,
but that's not helping shit.
[inaudible]
to Kinda fresh though.
Go back to his boots.
Yeah man,
that guy looks like his boots.
Can you make them boots larger?
Look at those fresh boots.
I wear those on stage.
Would I get in trouble for cultural appropriation?
Wherein in stuff,
if they're white to work and know that if they're more powerful than you,
then you're okay.
Like how does that work?
How does that work?
You can't take from how much,
what percentage of native American do you have to have in you to wear moccasins?
Who a lot hassle jacket.
How about the,
like the Suede tasseled jacket.
They're like Roger Daltrey.
It's like good rebels in the 70s war.
I wanted one of those so bad when I was in high school.
They look so cool.
The easy rider with the fringe on it.
It's all moving.
Driving,
man.
I wanted the arm out the window with the car and it's flopping around.
Yeah.
You're on stage singing.
The ladies must love yet.
Look at that.
Ah,
oh,
Gloria.
Come on.
Strips of leather.
See,
but that goes too far,
so you have it because they have the native American thing.
I'm asleep.
You see this one right here?
No,
not that other one.
Well,
that one's,
yeah,
it's too far.
That one.
If you do that one,
you better kill the bear that you use for those fuckers.
Yeah,
that's too,
that's ridiculous.
Now there's a white guy version of that,
which would be okay.
That's a girl claims to be a healer,
right?
Yeah,
that's who would wear that.
See if you were that in Texas.
You're okay.
Excellent.
Yeah.
Okay.
Daniel Boone?
Yeah.
Out of here with that one.
That one's dark,
dark one.
No.
What do you prints if be like that guy?
What are you a has to light?
Bat looks terrible.
It looks terrible.
He's got the fringe on the bottom.
That's what's going to separate us from everybody else.
The curtains on the bottom or fringe.
A Nice curtain in a fine,
a fine restaurant.
We'll get Elvis.
Elvis had tassels.
Elvis had rainbow tassels.
You could get away with it if you're Elvis,
if you,
if you're working for enterprise,
rent a car,
I think you may be.
You don't wear that?
Yeah.
Elvis got away with some wild shit.
Who the fuck would jumpsuits before Elvis jumpsuits?
It was him and evil Knievel.
Okay.
Oh Man,
look at that Hendrix.
Oh my God.
That's,
yeah dude.
See,
but he's doing some of these playing the guitar.
He's moving around.
He's got a headband.
If you just,
if you're making snow cones,
you don't,
that's not your jacket,
man.
I wanted one when I was in high school,
I wore my,
see,
I literally never put that back up.
Put that picture back up.
Look at that.
That look.
How good does it look and I could never wear it.
He's got friends Gianna yet.
What does that greenish yellow,
how would you describe that color?
It's like a teal,
like a light teal light teal.
He's got,
he's got bell bottoms.
They'll bottom jeans,
washed bell bottoms,
and he's got this cool jacket with fringes that are literally two feet long and
then a headband to,
and it's just his kind of Fuchsia that had been,
right.
It's kind of reddish.
Yeah,
like a light red and he's,
it's on Jimi Hendrix.
That's the,
that's the thing that we can't match when we could buy all those items,
but it's still our head.
It's Jimi Hendrix's knowing that it's 2019 two.